[Music]
welcome back
in the last video we derived gauss's
divergence theorem which is an extremely
powerful
equality in vector calculus that allows
us to derive partial differential
equations
so in particular what gauss's theorem
allows us to do is equate
the
flux of a quantity through some surface
s
given by let's say i have a fluid flow
given by this vector field f and that
fluid flow is moving material mass and
energy and momentum around in space
and if i want to compute how much of
that quantity is passing through this
surface s
i can compute that one of two ways i can
either compute that by integrating this
vector field f
dot it into the normal direction and
integrate that along the surface that
would essentially add up how all of the
stuff is moving through the surface
or
equivalently and this is gauss's
divergence theorem i can compute the
divergence of f everywhere in this
volume and integrate up all of those
divergences over the entire volume
so it essentially gives us a way of
equating a volume integral of
divergences
that equals a surface integral of this f
dotted into the normal and we used it in
the last lecture to derive this mass
conservation equation this this mass
continuity partial differential equation
assuming that we have uh some some fluid
flow carrying mass you know that has
some density rho
so rho is the density of my fluid in all
of space and time it's a scalar function
and this vector field f is moving mass
around it's just moving air or water
around let's say in the in the
atmosphere or in the ocean or something
like that
and so
we could write that the total rate of
change of mass in my volume
is equal to the amount of mass that is
being carried in and carried out
of that volume by the fluid
so if i have a total net amount of fluid
leaving
the volume so f dot n is positive if i
have a total amount of fluid leaving the
volume through the surface of this then
that would correspond to a negative rate
of change of mass inside the volume this
is just basic accounting
and again gauss's divergence theorem
says that i can take this surface
integral
integrating up around the surface
and i can write that as a volume
integral for the divergence of that
quantity that i'm computing
and so maybe i'll just make this very
explicit
this step here is where we used gauss's
theorem okay so this step from the
surface integral to this volume integral
is how we used gauss's divergence
theorem
that allowed us to take this quantity
here which is in a volume integral
and get another expression under a
volume integral so i can have them kind
of under the same volume integral and
what we said is that this is true for
all volumes v
and so essentially if this is true for
all volumes you get this partial
differential equation so the thing
inside has to equal 0 if this integral
is equal to 0 for all volumes v
that's just kind of a nice physical
argument
now i want to do a few things here i
want to point out
these conservation laws are extremely
powerful you if you draw a volume
you know a sufficiently large volume v
this is called a control volume
sometimes in fluids or in physics
this can include things like you know if
there is a nuclear bomb going off in
that or if i have
you know i don't know some
death star
creating you know some focused laser
that explodes a planet
okay if my control volume is large
enough that it includes all of those
effects and it's kind of you know large
enough that that it includes that
then this basic conservation is still
going to be true
uh inside of this volume so it's a very
very powerful idea is to compute these
integrals over these volumes
couple things i want to point out that i
did not include in my last lecture and i
want to make this a little more general
so
the total rate of change of mass in my
volume is equal to the amount of mass
carried out of the volume or into the
volume
but you can also have plus
uh a source term some volume integral of
a source term dv
so for example if i actually detonated a
nuclear bomb inside of my control volume
i'm actually converting mass purely into
energy and so i actually would have a
negative q
very locally at this point i would have
a negative q
and i'd have to integrate that up over
the volume
so technically speaking my expression
here is only true if mass is neither
created nor destroyed if the quantity
i'm conserving is not created or
destroyed
but if you can have a source of q either
you know maybe you um
you create mass from energy or maybe you
destroy mass and it turns into energy
then you can have these source terms
added to this equation
and it would basically be this equation
equals
you know a source term there would be
some source term in space and time
uh forcing this partial differential
equation okay so that's that's one
important thing is that uh we need to
think about
is the assumption of mass conservation
really true
for a simple fluid flow if i just follow
you know the fluid flow in the ocean
absolutely mass is not being created or
destroyed if i follow you know the air
in the atmosphere even if a jet's flying
through it mass is not being created or
destroyed but sometimes when i have a
complicated enough physical process like
you know i'm actually fusing atoms or
splitting atoms then i might actually
have to have these source terms here but
that's the really cool thing about
kind of partial differential equations
and control volumes and gauss's theorem
is that you can still apply these
arguments if you're careful even you
know if your control volume has really
gnarly physics going on
uh now
everything is always true in the control
volume sense this is always true this
expression here okay the one that i've
written here and i'm highlighting with
my hand
always true
when we convert it into this expression
here using gauss's divergence theorem
and when we say that this is true for
all volumes v
to get this partial differential
equation
that step relies on the quantity where
we're saying is conserved mass momentum
energy and the fluid flow that's
carrying it around f
being sufficiently smooth or continuous
that i can kind of take the limit over
any volume and still have this be true
and remember that picture i showed with
the divergence where we uh we kind of
split this into a bunch of boxes and we
had a bunch of local divergences that
cancelled out
if i have a abrupt enough change in my
vector field so it abruptly changes like
that if i have a shock function you know
a step function in f or i have a shock
wave so i have an instantaneous change
in rho
then that argument that pillbox argument
that gauss's theorem is derived on that
these are essentially canceling each
other out that kind of breaks down okay
and so that just gives you some idea
that if your
f or your row if the thing you're
carrying around and if the vector field
that's carrying it around if those are
discontinuous
then you can't kind of take this step
here the gauss's theorem step and you
can't remove this volume integral
because if i have a discontinuous row or
f
these will kind of blow up to infinity i
can't compute the derivative of a step
function and have it still be finite so
this doesn't really make sense for
discontinuous functions like shock waves
and so that's actually why if we look at
you know supersonic jets i really need
to think about it in a control volume
setting it's harder to think about it
using using these pdes okay
so that's i think something i really
wanted to to point out just so that you
know you can include kind of other
physics like sources and sinks you know
creation and destruction of mass
through these source terms and the step
where we go from a volume integral to a
partial differential equation relies on
things being smooth this doesn't work
for shock waves and discontinuous
dynamics you kind of have to work in the
control volume if that's if that's the
case
and you can still compute these things
approximately numerically and so that's
okay we can still compute
you know what happens but we we
sometimes have to use different
computational strategies
good
now what i want to point out
is if rho is constant so if rho is
constant then we have an incompressible
flow
literally means like if you if you take
liquid water liquid water is very very
hard to to compress it's very hard to
change the density of your water you can
smash it you can you know accelerate it
you can do all this stuff the density of
your water is not going to change much
okay
and so that's an incompressible fluid
air the air that is around us if i just
wave my arms or move
you know my mouth or whatever
that air is also approximately
incompressible on these time scales if i
just move my hand i can feel a breeze
but that density is really not changing
just because i'm moving my hands
you have to go you know close to the
speed of sound so you have to go to like
mock point
point 0.3 or 0.1 or you know some some
appreciable
uh fraction of the speed of sound
before you actually start stacking up
and compressing the air and changing its
density uh in space and time
so
my point being that
this equation is general enough to
handle fully compressible
fluid flows where the density changes
this is okay you know for jets flying
where the the density of the air is
actually changing because they're kind
of ramming the air together and forming
these these kind of density waves
but if the air or the water is
incompressible if the density doesn't
change at all then we can derive special
conditions on this differential equation
so that's what i want to do now
and this is kind of an exercise to get
you thinking about how you can
manipulate these things with more
physical knowledge so here we only use
mass conservation but again if we know
something extra like we have constant
density we can do even more we can
simplify this even more
so let's do that
what i'm going to do is i am going to
actually compute what this term looks
like so if i have
uh
del dot
f
and again we're going to assume that f
has three components let's say that this
is um
f1 f2 f3 and these are all functions of
x y and z and time okay so this is an
unsteady flow in space and time
then this is equal to
partial partial x
of
rho f1
plus partial uh partial
y of row f2
plus partial partial z of rho
f3 and i feel like i'm going to make a
typo so just please follow along
carefully and make sure that you agree
with
with this
now if rho can vary then i actually have
to compute this derivative using the
chain rule this would be partial row
partial x f1 plus rho partial f1 partial
x
and so i'm actually going to write this
out maybe i'll change colors here so
this equals
and i'm going to use subscript to denote
partial derivative so this would equal
rho sub x
f1
plus rho
f
1 sub x that's the partial of f1 with
respect to x okay that's the first term
plus
same thing rho sub y
f2
plus rho
f2 sub y
and now the third term is
rho sub z
f3
plus rho f3 sub z partial of f3 with
respect to z and i can collect my terms
here i can collect my like terms i can
take all of my rows
that have no partial derivatives
and i can take all of my
rows that do have partial derivatives
and i can bring those into into two
different expressions and so what this
equals
is um
this equals
all of my let's let's take my yellow
terms first here so this is rho times
the divergence of f this is rho times
div dot f
okay that's you know
partial of f1 with respect to x plus
partial of f2 with respect to y plus
partial of f3 with respect to z that's
the divergence of f
so these yellow terms are just row times
the divergence of f
the pink terms
are
the gradient of rho literally grad rho
rho sub x rho sub y rho sub z
dotted with
f
so rho sub x times the first component
of f
rho sub y
times the second component of f rho sub
z times the third component of f that's
the gradient of rho
dotted with f
and so so i'm just showing you kind of
what we do when we when we kind of do
the chain rule to this expression here
my divergence of rho times f the the
momentum the mass that's being carried
through with f
gives me these two terms here
so here's where it gets interesting okay
if
i got to giving myself a place to live
if
the fluid
is incompressible
incompressible fluid like water liquid
water is a great example or
i don't know if mercury is
incompressible i guess it is if my fluid
is incompressible i guess liquids in
general are incompressible typically if
my fluid is incompressible
then
rho is a constant
the density is a constant the density
can't be changed just by moving the
fluid around
and if the density is constant then what
that means is that partial rho partial t
is equal to zero
like it can't change in time
and
uh the div sorry the gradient of row
is equal to zero rho doesn't change as i
move along in x or y or z okay it's a
constant
and so if my fluid is incompressible so
if my density is a constant if rho is a
constant then these two things have to
be true
and what that means is that this term is
zero
and when i split this into these two
terms the pink term has to be 0 also
and so what i end up getting when i
expand this out i have
partial rho partial t
plus
rho
divergence of f
plus
gradient of rho
dotted with f
all of that equals again this originally
equaled zero when i uh didn't have
uh
you know when i didn't have some source
term this all equals zero
but because of my incompressibility
uh this term is zero and the gradient of
row is equal to zero and so and rho is a
constant i can just divide both sides by
row
and so what that means
is that i have for an incompressible
flow
the divergence of my fluid vector field
f
has to equal 0.
again this
is the mass continuity equation for
incompressible flows this means that my
flows have to be divergence free so if i
have the flow of liquid water you know
around the ocean kind of the gulf stream
or whatever
that flow has to be divergence free
to satisfy the incompressibility of rho
and that's a really really powerful
result again we use gauss's theorem to
derive the basic basic partial
differential equation for how mass moves
around in a fluid and that can include
all kinds of weird effects you know
compressible effects
but if we know that our fluid is
incompressible like liquid water so we
know that rho is a constant we can do
things like kill off different terms in
the equation and get a simpler
expression
for that vector field f
so this
divergence free condition or this kind
of continuity equation the divergence of
f equals 0
is a really really important equation
for incompressible flows this is a
statement of conservation of mass for
incompressible flows
if my density doesn't change this is how
mass is conserved
okay so that gives you an idea of kind
of um some of the caveats how you can
extend this to include even more
interesting physics
when you can and cannot go from a volume
integral to a
real honest-to-goodness partial
differential equation for example if you
have shock waves in your flow or
discontinuities
you know supersonic jets would be a case
like that
and then also how if you have extra
knowledge about your fluid if you know
something about this this flow like the
density is constant for incompressible
flows
then you can get even simpler
expressions like
this is the exact same expression for an
incompressible flow
so really cool stuff we can also use
this kind of basic framework instead of
carrying around mass conservation in a
volume we could keep track of the
conservation of momentum in a volume and
we would derive instead of the
continuity equation the navy or stokes
equations so the navy or stokes
equations are kind of this exact
procedure
for the conservation of momentum in a
volume with a fluid carrying it around
you could also do this for the
conservation of energy again if you had
thermal flows or you know combusting
flows or you know nuclear blast flows
you need an energy equation to keep
track of kind of the thermodynamics of
the situation too but again as long as
you know basic conservation laws that
stuff just doesn't come from nowhere you
know there's source terms and sync terms
maybe
you can derive these pdes and analyze
them all right thank you